[موسيقى]
بين الساحل الأطلسي
وجبال الأطلس والصحراء الكبرى
تقع مدينة المساء مدينة صغيرة على
الساحل الجنوبي الغربي للمغرب
تعاني القرى المجاورة لها من
الجفاف لمكافحة هذا التنظيم الوحيد الذي يستخدم
تقنية قديمة لمصدر المياه وليس
من  منذ قرون من الآبار أو
هطول الأمطار في بعض الأحيان ، ولكن من خلال حصاد الضباب ،
فإن التكنولوجيا قديمة للغاية في الواقع ، إنها تقنية قديمة
كانت موجودة في جميع أنحاء العالم أينما كانت
هناك
أحداث ضباب كثيفة للغاية
ستجدها في منطقة جنوب إفريقيا التي
وجدتها  في المغرب وجزر الكناري
تجدها في كاليفورنيا
تجدها أيضًا في أمريكا الجنوبية ، لذا
حيثما توجد تيارات باردة
تخلق ضبابًا كثيفًا جدًا يمكن
حصاده
[موسيقى]
ولكن أيضًا جميلة براغاس هي المؤسس المشارك
لدارسي حميد
منظمة في مهمة لمساعدة
المنطقة في الحصول على
المياه تستخدم المنظمات غير الربحية شباكًا ضخمة موضوعة
على قمم الجبال على ارتفاع ألف متر
فوق مستوى سطح البحر.  إخراج قطرات صغيرة
من الماء من الضباب الكثيف ، يمر
عبر شبكة دقيقة
ثم يتجمع في خزان يشبه الأنابيب
[موسيقى]
مياه الضباب هي مياه نقية لا تحتوي على أي
معادن ، لذا يجب خلطها
بالمياه الجوفية أو المياه السطحية التي
تحتوي على معادن
يمكن حصاد حوالي 6000 لتر من المياه
يوميًا شريان حياة لما يقرب من
1000 شخص في القرى المجاورة
[موسيقى]
لدينا
16 قرية تعمل بكامل طاقتها
حوالي
137 أسرة وقد أضفنا
12 قرية أخرى وفقًا للأمم المتحدة
أكثر من 2 مليار شخص
صراع عالمي من ندرة المياه ،
إنه تحدٍ يومي
أحد التحديات الرئيسية التي تواجهنا اليوم
في هذا العالم هو التفكير في كيفية
إدارتنا للمياه وأزمة المياه المعبأة
وهذه العلاقة بين بيئة الأعمال
والإدارة هي شيء نحتاج إلى
إعادة التفكير فيه  النموذج الذي
نستخدمه اليوم
[موسيقى]
دارشي حمد هو مثال
لإيجاد الماء من الهواء الرقيق مما يسمح
للمجتمعات ليس فقط بالبقاء على قيد الحياة
بل بالازدهار